- On this episode,
the winners join me.
Let's clap it up.
(applause)
(hip hop music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is
The #AskGaryVee Show
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 125
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
It's a glorious Friday here,
that's a good meaning--
I actually woke up in Detroit.
Actually, you know what happened today?
It was the first time in forever,
for all the insanity that
is my life in traveling
that I woke up, 4:45am
that I woke up and
wasn't sure where I was.
Like rolled out, literally (laughs)
Mike I hope you're not watching.
Literally rolled out
of bed and I was like,
"Ugh, I gotta go work out."
I'm like, oh no wait, I'm in Detroit
I gotta fly and then go work out.
(laughs)
So that is going on, nothing else.
Nothing too out of the ordinary otherwise,
except a packed house.
Let's get a little like, here we go.
Let's get a little bit of a
roam on who's in the room.
And them I'm gonna allow the three newbies
in the room to introduce themselves.
Because obviously today is the day
that we are announcing
(laughs)
or displaying the winners
of the contest to come.
Today is the special day that is--
today is the official one.
So one year, actually, you know what?
I'm pumped everyone's here because,
truth is, I think we did this once before
somewhere 60 episodes ago.
Let's just do it one more time
and then we'll let you
three wonderful winners
introduce yourselves to the Vayner Nation.
What happened ago, a year ago today?
Should we go to Steve here, I think?
(laughs)
- I got one of those like Gary emails
that was all in the subject
line and it was like,
guys, we're gonna do
daily YouTube show again.
Let's do this.
- That was really it?
- And we were like, all right.
- I remember at the beginning
of the year it was like,
this is gonna be the year of YouTube.
And then you like went off
on a bunch of other stuff,
and we were like, oh I guess not YouTube.
And then all of a
sudden, it was just like,
we're doing YouTube again.
- Well, it's 'cause we hired DRock.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, DRock you were
how long in at this point?
- [Voiceover] A month.
- A month in?
And so what--
You can go to D-Rock.
Had we--
And DRock, you can go to
me 'cause you can like--
(laughs)
And so, DRock,
did you and I, had we been
flirting with the idea?
- No.
(laughs)
- [DRock] You came into
the room, you're like,
we're gonna do a talk
show and I'm like, okay.
And you're like, face the camera this way.
I'm like, okay.
(laughs)
And then--
- And there it was.
And so, a year ago today
we did this. (snaps)
Hey everybody welcome to
the first #AskGaryVee.
I think it's the first one
but I actually do think
I tried to do this once before.
I feel like I've got the team now in place
to actually do this more often.
So here we go.
And, obviously we'll
do a little clip there
for a couple of seconds.
We should be black and white here.
(laughs)
All right, good.
All right, so we did a contest
for this amazing one year anniversary
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
125 episodes in one year
not too shabby considering
weekends involved,
five days a week, you
know, you're talking about
250 days or whatever it really is, 52.
You're talking about a really
solid level of commitment
to the show, something I
always like to talk about.
People giving up, I always talk about
it being a year and a half
before Wine Library TV
really clicked everyday,
it was five days a week.
This commitment's been pretty good.
I'm a hell of a lot busier than I was
when I started Wine Library TV.
So, to get to this
level, I'm pretty proud.
So, let's get into the introductions.
Why don't you tell the Vayner Nation.
You can pass that to
someone else on the Meerkat.
(laughs)
Why don't you tell the Vayner Nation
who you are and why don't we give you guys
each kinda like 30 seconds to
do whatever you want with it.
You can juggle, take your shirt off.
(laughs)
Promote, you can do
whatever the hell you want.
- Thanks, Gary (clears throat), excuse me.
I'm Dallas Hutchinson
@DHuntchinsonRE on Twitter.
It's gonna be down here, maybe.
- Yes. (laughs)
It's nice to have people
that know the show.
- Dallas Hutchinson on Instagram.
That might be up here.
(laughs)
But I'm a real estate entrepreneur
from southern California.
And I'm just honestly happy to be here.
A lot of people have asked me,
you know, what I do.
Or what my hook, or what my angle was
to get on the show.
Quite frankly I knocked it out
in ten minutes with my thumbs
I wrote from the heart
and now here I am.
So, that's all I got.
If you wanna check out my homes,
it's dallashutchinson.com
And thanks, Gary.
- Yeah, when did you--
tell me about your journey
to the show, like show.
- From yesterday?
- No.
(laughs)
- 'Cause that was journey in itself.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- You could do that on
your own fucking blog.
(laughs)
When did you discover the show?
How did you discover the show?
- Well, I was--
I don't know how long
I've been following you
but I've seen every episode.
I've definitely been
following you probably since
March-ish, somewhere around there.
I don't remember how I found you,
I just remembered from
the first 30 seconds
of whatever show I caught, I said this guy
is not fucking around.
(laughs)
He's not trying to sell me anything.
He's not full of shit.
He has an incredible amount of energy.
He talks very quickly like I do.
I just instantly could relate.
- You tasted it (fingers snap) that fast.
- (fingers snap) That quick.
- That's awesome man, glad you're here.
Awesome, all right, now the ladies corner.
Get outta here, Zach.
(laughs)
Actually, get back here Zach.
The hat is amazing.
How are you, darling?
- Great, how are you?
- Good, why don't you tell
everybody who you are.
- Hey guys, my name is Webly Alfred
from weblyalfreddesign.com
Where I help small
business owner eliminate,
tech issues and nail it on social media.
Did you like the plug?
- I did, I did, it was very radiant.
You were very radio, Webly.
- Thank you.
- How did you enter the contest?
What was your strategy?
Two thumbs, ten minutes, how do you roll?
- Actually, I entered the contest,
I checked my email
after a long day of work
and I thought it was
an interesting question
and I'd just finish reading Crush It!
and the first thing
that came to my mind was
how I could relate to you,
to your family as immigrants.
- [Gary] It worked.
- I just answered the first
thing that came to my mind.
- I love it.
And how about the show?
How did you--(laughs)
How did you find it?
How did you, how long
have you been following?
- I find out about the
show when your book,
Jab Jab Right Hook came out.
And I said, "Let me find
out about this guy."
And the first video, I was like, you know
finally, somebody who is
telling it like it is.
Who's not sugar coating it.
Who's saying the truth that you need
to put some hustle out there.
And I was hooked.
- Awesome, awesome, I'm glad you made it.
- Thank you.
- All right, my man.
Let me, I don't know.
Don't worry, DRock knows what to do.
That's it, he's got you.
You stay right there.
- [Voiceover] Stay here.
- You stay there, I'll--
We'll connect through--
We'll hold hands.
(laughs)
- Okay, so I'm--
My name's Matthew Chaim.
(laughs)
@MatthewChaim on everything.
So follow me there.
(laughs)
And yeah, I'm--
We're gonna do this holding--
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- I'm mainly a musician.
A singer and a rapper, songwriter.
And I also dabble in some
video making and marketing.
So, wearing a few hats.
And yeah, how I found you?
I read that (fingers
snap) book right there,
Jab Jab Jab Right Hook, and loved it.
And then found the show a few months later
and I didn't get addicted
to it right away.
- Interesting.
- I'd watch it a bit here and there
but I wasn't so into it.
My, one of my co-workers, my boss
is actually really into
it, he turned me onto it.
- Is he super pissed that you're here?
- He's not because he's
not this type of guy.
He doesn't wanna be, he's watching.
He's gonna watch it, he's gonna love it.
- Got it, yeah.
- So he's actually like
so honestly excited for me
because he's not the extroverted type.
- He's behind the camera.
- Yeah, exactly.
- He's like Sid the Intern.
- He's living vicariously, yeah exactly.
(laughs)
And then, it honestly taught me a lesson
on consistency 'cause you kept doing it.
I was like, oh my god, like
and then I started watching it
more and more and more until
it became like a habit.
It's like a daily habit now to
check if there's a new video.
And yeah, I went all the
way back, watched everything
and yeah, absolutely.
- Awesome brother, glad you're here Matt.
Is Meerkat working, crashed?
- [Voiceover] It's Meerkating.
- It's Meerkating.
- [Voiceover] It's doing its thing.
- Got it.
- [Voiceover] We're getting there.
- All right, DRock
you're out of it today.
(laughs)
Matthew's in.
All right well, with
that, that's tremendous.
I'm glad Vayner Nation
now knows you three.
I'm sorta pumped for you guys,
this is day that I will
always remember, I love this.
Maybe we'll do this again
in another 100 episodes
if we're still doing the
show, with that, Webly.
This is a very exciting part.
- It is.
- Webly, let's get into
- The show.
- The show
(laughs)
All right, cool.
- Okay, the first question in from Amber.
- Amber.
- Amber says, if you
lost everything today,
what's the first thing
you would do to rebuild?
- What would be the first--
So the first thing that, you
know, this is a tough question
because I'm trying to give you guys
the truth in parallel with
what would be valuable.
Meaning, what I would
do if I lost everything.
It's an interesting question.
There's two versions of it.
I lost everything 'cause
I actually just bet big.
Let's say, for example,
with Snapchat's last round,
I really, really came close to betting
the biggest I've ever bet.
Meaning, if I would lose,
it would've really hurt.
Hurt as in, like changed my lifestyle.
I've never made a bet that
would change my lifestyle before
and I almost considered it.
I didn't because that's just
been my consistent theme.
And it was funny, I got to
think about that a little bit.
I think I spoke or maybe this
is when I spoke to the interns
DRock, was this with the
interns when I told them
how secretly I did wanna
go to zero, I think it was.
So we didn't do hit this on the show.
I'm very comfortable going back
to a studio apartment in Queens.
Like Rocky VI or whatever the hell it was
where he's like back in the same place.
I'm like, yeah.
(laughs)
Everyone's like, oh.
No, I don't like Rocky III
where he's got a fucking robot butler.
I like Rocky VI where he's back to zero.
Because I'm comfortable in that zone.
I'm comfortable in all environments.
I'm not comfortable 'cause
it might be tough for my kids
and my family and all those things.
Let's make pretend I lost everything,
including my name and reputation.
Right, because if I was
to lose something today,
I'd still have my name and reputation.
It's be interesting
because I would be a zero
or really in this bad place and here I am.
Am I in a position to dole out advice?
One of the things that I think,
I think I've earned the
ability for you three
to listen to me because
unlike, I think the thing
that you're all referring to
which is finally
somebody's saying (laughs)
it's because I'm not just entertaining.
It's not because I read Napoleon Hill
and decided to be like
influential on someone.
It's because I actually
did something first
and I just happen to
talk about how I did it
and then I'm very consistent down the line
and then you can figure out
what's like that with you.
And what's not like that with you.
And how to--
I try to create a line
everyone can navigate around.
I don't say do it like me.
I'm special.
I'm charismatic.
I'm left brain, right brain.
I have disproportionate
amount of hustle in my body.
I've got talent for days.
I'm special.
And everybody else is special
in what they're good at too.
I don't know these stupid
lights that DRock has, right?
I don't have a duck
fucking tattoo on my arm.
(laughs)
I'm not that creative.
Right?
And so like, listen.
- [India] It's not a duck.
- What is it?
- It's a loon.
I don't have a--(laughs)
And there in lies the point.
(laughs)
And so, I think that
if I started from zero
without my reputation,
I would do a couple of things.
One, I would get a nine to five job.
So that's a little bit of a curve ball.
Because I need to establish
some sort of cash flow, right?
I would literally do that
for one psychological reason
because I would have to
teach Lizzie and my kids
that clearly what I've
been selling and preaching,
I've made a really bad turn on
and I'm gonna show you
that I'm not beneath that.
Now, I think within a month
I probably be selling on Ebay
to subsidize what that was.
But more importantly,
what I'm trying to really
figure out here as a
tangible piece of advice is
if somebody's watching
right now and it's funny,
the audience is getting
younger and younger.
I'm paying attention to
who's resonating with me.
I think there's a lot of people that are
at a very low kind of financial
point in their careers.
Definitely reputation
point in their careers low.
I think the thing that I would do
is I would bet on what I'm good at
which is, I'm good at selling stuff.
So I do think that I know
how to make a 100,000 dollars
a year which is a shit load of money.
Let's just get it very calculated.
99% of the people watching this show
probably don't make that much money.
Let's get it calibrated.
I know how to make 100,000 dollars a year
by garage selling 52 weekends a year.
I just do.
I know how to go to
Goodwill and Salvation Army
and garage saling and then
flipping things on Ebay
and so I'd probably do that first.
Start using some of that cash
to start an Ecom business
using the money that I
make in garage saling
to sell stuff online.
Something that's more scalable
than the garage sale stuff.
A product, probably. (laughs)
It's so weird, it's so funny.
Notice what I'm just doing.
I just realized in real life,
I'm literally replicating what I did.
I was a merchant hustler kid.
And then I went and sold
a tangible product in Ecom
and then, I would just
probably replicate my life.
(laughs)
And it's interesting, it's
interesting that I didn't even
realize that I was saying
that until just this moment.
So, that's what I would do.
I was start by slinging some stuff adhoc.
Then I would create a
scalable selling product
using the best practices
and that's what I would do.
Cool.
- [India] It's a great segue.
- It's a great segue?
- [Voiceover] Totally rocked it, yeah.
- [Voiceover] Gary?
- Yes.
- [Steve] Your 12:30 just canceled.
- My 12:30 just canceled?
Huge.
Lack of pressure.
(laughs)
Actually, I didn't like that,
you shouldn't have told me.
I like when--
You might've just--
(overlapping chatter)
Got it, okay.
- Okay, next question is from Charles.
What would you do in a world
where money had no value?
Where you couldn't sell shit?
- Wow.
(laughs)
I'm gonna throw a lot of
people for a curve ball here.
I actually wish that existed.
I actually think that I would
be even more successful.
I think I have, I think
I'm doing fine financially.
I'm actually, in my behavior,
I wish my accountant was here.
I'm very conservative, way
more than people think.
I don't value the dollars that much.
I'm not--
We should go into James' office right now.
Of all the money I'm leaving
on the table at VaynerMedia
because I like the feelings
and all the other things
that come along in life, I
actually think that if the world
had no money that I
would be more successful.
Because I think, and I've eluded to this,
that my ability to communicate to people
and to storytell and
to inspire and motivate
is maybe my disproportional skill.
And that if I wasn't drawn
to running businesses,
that I would be absolutely
in hype-man P. Diddy
or preacher.
I push very hard against
my motivational aspect
because I don't wanna be bucketed
into a motivational
speaker because I do think
that it's the cliche thing
that we talked about earlier
that you two really hit on.
And I'm scared that people
struggle to cut through the noise
which is why I'm impressed with the--
You know it's funny, you two
are the most interesting for me
because you're both the parallels
that happen with me right?
There's only one third person
that wasn't your story,
it would've been perfect
of the three versions
of my content that's put out.
Instantaneous understanding.
Perseverance, but liked it up
front but it was perseverance.
And, at some level,
thank god you're not this
but like the, this guy's full of shit
and I just eventually got
there and won that game, right?
So I actually think that if the
world was stripped of money,
that I would be dramatically
more impactful on society.
And the weirdest and only scenario
that ever goes through my mind.
Ever.
Of me not buying the New York Jets.
Is that somewhere along the line,
the chemicals inside
tweak just enough
to where I become
guilted by myself
to give up that part of my journey
to triple down on the other
part of my journey a/k this.
It's a funny story, somebody
sent me an email yesterday
and said they were
disappointed in me for sending
the email and creating the contest
of asking for the books
to be in the question.
And I sat there with the
question for like 20 minutes,
I said, "My god, I will
never win this game
because people are unable
to see one level deep."
(scoffs)
I'm not forcing people to buy that book.
I'm putting out a show every single day
that is free in a world where plenty
of people monetize video content.
And you're more the
welcome not to participate
in that part of it and I am
picking 500 other questions
to put in there and it's just interesting
that there's so little breathing room
for any kind of commerce to some people
in a world where you could
provide dispropotionate
upfront value and people
want you to be stuck
in the jab, jab, jab, jab world
and I'm wired as a jab,
jab, jab, right hook guy.
If money was taken out
and the game of business was stripped.
I would then have less of a
right hook mentality of commerce
My right hook would then be to
get people to actually do it.
So I'd be like chasing all
of you around and be like,
"No, you gotta go do it."
Now, motivation isn't enough.
I actually think the
answer to your question
in a long-winded way is
I'd be really happy
and really successful in
communicating to the world
my points of view.
- [Voiceover] Love it.
- Cool, let's go Webly.
Speed it up.
- Mike Pond asks, I think it's a waste--
- Mike?
- [Webly] Yep, Mike.
- Okay.
- [Webly] I think it's waste of my time
to comment on your videos
and answer the question of the day.
Tell me why I'm wrong.
- Well, Mike.
Let me help you tell you why you're wrong.
- [Voiceover] Here we go. (laughs)
- No, I think it's a
really interesting question
and I think that--
Mike, I think it's a great question
and I think that there's
a couple of things
to figure out here.
One, I'm gonna assume, maybe not,
that one of the good reasons
to think what you think
and I think a lot of other people think,
there is because I'm
not reading that right?
Like why say something if
it's not being consumed.
I think a lot of people
recognize I do read them
because I'm engaging quite a bit.
Not on YouTube which is because of the app
and because I have a
awkward sign-in structure
on Google between Gary@vaynermedia
and the account we use for
a lot of the Google content.
I have to figure that out.
I would comment more
because now it's all mobile,
I only comment mobilely.
So, I've gotta figure that out
but quite a bit on Twitter.
Outrageous levels on Facebook
in the last month or so.
More on YouTube, I will figure it out.
I will use this as call to action.
But now I'm gonna give
you a really good answer
to your question.
The reason you're actually
gonna start commenting.
It's because I have nothing
to do with the equation
of what's actually happening here.
Let me explain.
That's not fair.
I do have something to do with it.
I'm (claps) the match of what's happening
with the #AskGaryVee Show.
But the truth is, to really
get what I want out of it,
I want to build a comminity.
A community can not be built
predicated on a dictatorship
or an individual.
It needs to be predicated on the fact
that people are communicating
with each other.
What you haven't realized yet, Mike,
is that if you look deeply into
what's going on on Instagram
and YouTube and Facebook
there is a group of 30 to 40 people
that are quietly and
subtly, and I would say
of those 40 people, 25 are
doing the wrong version of it.
Which they're in there
communicating with the other people
for their own interest in
mind to siphon them into--
If Webly was to do that, she's
in there 'cause she wants
some of the other small business
people to take her services
and that's all she wants
in a right hook, right hook
right hook, right hook way.
25 of you, I'm paying attention,
are playing that game.
15 of you are not,
you're playing more of a
jab, jab, jab, right hook game
and let's just remind everybody,
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook
to that person that
emailed and said they were
disappointed in me,
that is a game that plays like this.
Jab, jab, jab, right hook.
The right hook is not
you get the sale.
The right hook is
you've been given the permission
to have a chance to sell.
So, when you jab, jab, jab and right hook
you go for your right hook
but you're not disappointed.
I have not even asked
any single person here
what the update is on how
many books have come in.
It's just not the part, it's
the permission that it created,
not necessarily what the
results are just yet.
The real reason you should
be commenting on this show
is because you'd start putting
out content on your two cents
in context to what was just
put out in the show format.
Other people that are in the trenches
are actually reading
those comments, plenty.
More of you should be.
And then you start
engaging with each other.
And out of that serendipity,
much like on Wine Library TV,
where there are over 20
different wine tasting groups
right now that have been
hanging out with each other
for the last seven to ten
years drinking wine together,
once out of every, once a
month on every third Wednesday
for the last five years
and have built their
disproportionate best
friends out of being part
of a community of a web
show started by some kid
in New Jersey talking about wine.
The community that's being
built underneath here.
The way that these three get
to interact with each other
for the rest of their lives
on this connection point
and the way that you guys
all have the ability,
if you'd like to, to create
connections of likeminded people
with very different angles and
to have an interesting situation
unlike politics or
religion or other things
where you have a guy who's a pardox
which then creates fan
bases in opposite directions
so it's not a complete sheep
game but yet people that can
actually have empathy for
other people's points of view
and collaborate, you
now have the beginnings
of a community that has value to you
that has nothing to do with the person
that's putting out the content.
That, my friend, is why
you should be commenting.
You like that, India?
(laughs)
You like that?
- [India] We're into clapping these days.
- Got it. (laughs)
- [Voiceover] They say you look bored.
- [India] I look bored?
- [Voiceover] That's what they're saying.
- [India] That's just my face.
(laughs)
- [Webly] The next one is a video.
- Okay, let's take it.
Oh, Draymond.
- Draymond.
- Look at this (laughs).
Hold on, show this guy's
outfit as this is playing.
(laughs)
- I didn't know, I swear.
- What's up Gary Vee, this Draymond Green.
I kinda been keeping up on
Facebook and your Twitter
and I saw where people were struggling
with identifying your passion
as opposed to calling it cockiness.
You know, along with
passion comes confidence
and I understand that well
'cause I'm the same way
when it comes to what I do.
I was just wondering,
how do you handle that?
It's something that I've
dealt with my whole life.
Where most, some people don't understand
that your love for
something or your passion
for what you're doing, it shines through
and people have a hard
time understanding that.
So I wanted to know what is
that you do to cope with that?
What is it that you do
to try to help people
better understand that?
And I think that can also
help take me into next level.
To the next level in what I do
and I wanna just find out how
it is that you handle that.
Look forward to hearing
back from you, thank you.
- All right, world champ,
Draymond Green on the show.
Staphon, you must --
- [Staphon] No, it's a great day.
(laughs)
- Thanks Draymond.
I think, you know--
First of all, thanks
for watching the show.
Show.
(laughs)
I have a feeling and
I've watched from afar
how you've been handling this as well
'cause you've clearly established yourself
especially with the Golden State Warriors
run to a championship this year.
A lot more people are aware of you
and you definitely come with a
lot of confidence and bravado
And really interesting, right?
Your story connects with me because you're
an undersized, power forward
who sometimes guards centers
in the NBA and now, I just
read an article the other day
that everybody in the
off-season is talking
about finding their
Draymond Green in the NBA.
That you've been
mentioned more than LeBron
this off-season about
how small ball can work.
You've literally, through
self confidence, perseverance
I also know a little bit about
how your mother raised you
so I caught that part of your narrative,
that's interesting to me.
I think we actually connect pretty well.
As a matter of fact, I
actually think that you and I
should play one on one.
(laughs)
In an episode of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Just to see if it's humanly
possible for me to score a point
I think this is one of
the things that I love
about people that think
they can play NBA players
on one-on-one.
I actually think that people don't realize
how pretty consistent an NBA player
against anybody who never
went past high school level
basketball can shut them out 11 - nothing
in a one-on-one game.
So I would be super pumped
if I could score points
with Draymond, that challenge is on.
I think you might duck me
because I think you're scared
and you know we're gonna film it.
(laughs)
But to answer your question,
to answer your question in full.
I think you just have to do you
and I think that's what you're doing.
I think I talk about the
truth being undefeated.
I'm a 39 year old man.
You're in your 20's, early, mid-20's.
Early 20's.
I know that you and I and
everybody in this room,
and everybody watching
and listening to the show,
we all want, we all
think about who we are.
Social media's been
really interesting to me
because I think social
media's been the first
tangible expression of how
everybody wants to PR themselves
to the world.
Even the people that poo-poo it
or try to play too cool for school
or don't believe in it,
they don't understand.
Subconsciously, every
single piece of content
that every person has ever
put out on social media
has been absolutely
thought through and is--
Not like, you're thinking about it.
It's been thought through subconsciously.
It is the action end
results of a narrative
that you've been painting in your mind
your whole life of who you are.
Who you want to be.
The ambition that you want.
I have outrageous disproportionate want
to be considered one of the
great businessmen of all time.
And want to be known about how I did it.
And they way I treated
people along the way.
I am very far away from that.
For as much as you guys love
me and as much as they--
You have to understand,
99% of the world has no idea who I am.
I have still not amassed
the kind of wealth
that can give me the halo effect
to talk about being a tangible
execution to that level.
So, I'm still so far away
but I know at 80 my
actions are gonna basically
be the result of my wants.
And I think you want to be great
and you've already, at such a young age,
hit the apex of your career
so you've got a different game
than I do but I think
along with, he's cocky
or he's this or she's cocky and she's that
comes all the stories behind the scenes
that people don't know.
That I'm sure, and I'm not sure.
I hope that behind the scenes
you're doing these things for fans.
And behind the scenes when
your competitor beats you,
even though you've put
everything to it, there's--
As much as I hate the
Patriots, as much as might
hate that you got knocked
out of the playoffs.
Even if you're kinda sour
about it, and I get sour.
If I lose 11-nothing, I
wouldn't even shake your hand.
Even though I'm telling you
to shake that person's hand
in my advice right now.
(laughs)
It's really there, it's that
respect level to the game.
I think as long as you respect the game
and respect, and this
something that I think
a lot of people struggle with.
I respect where I'm at right now.
Because it's the game.
I could think maybe I'm slightly behind.
I could think I should be
a little further along.
I'm just not.
And it's a net net game.
I think that you want people
to see you as self-confident
not egotistical.
You want people to see
that you're working hard,
that you're not cheap in the trenches.
So those actions just have
to be that way, right.
They just have to be that way.
So for me, I think you just do you
and let the chips fall where they may
and I have funny feeling you're okay
with what they're saying along the way
as long as you feel good about it.
And for me, that's my game too.
Plenty of people say things
and I just feel good about it.
I feel real damn good about it.
'Cause I'll see you.
I'll see you soon
and we'll talk about it.
- Cool.
- [India] Love it.
- [Webly] Next one, Vitaly.
- Vitaly.
Sounds like from the old country.
Where I come from.
- Gary?
- Yes.
- If Tom Brady asked you a question
on how to get out of his mess.
What would you tell him?
(laughs)
- Ugh, this is tough.
You know what's funny?
I actually had a very interesting moment
with myself yesterday.
Obviously, maybe some of you
saw this picture (fingers snap)
And a lot of people then put out,
did Gary Vee pay the
plane to fly over Boston
and say look up cheaters?
And it was funny, I was sitting
there and I had very, very--
I'mma tell you guys a story.
In 2008, in the midst of
Wine Library TV exploding,
it was the first time that I
was starting to get attention
at any kind of level
outside of a small circle.
I don't know if it was an
article or a conversation,
I don't remember.
But I read something about the notion of
that person or this story
I read was talking about
becoming a caricature of yourself.
And it really hit me, and
I was saying to myself,
huh, am I forcing the narrative?
Am I becoming more hyperbolized?
More energetic?
More intense?
To pander to what the
audience is giving me.
Am I becoming a caricature of myself?
And I don't know if I've ever
really answered it, right.
It was very difficult for
somebody that's really in tune,
I was really struggling to
unpeel the banana and be like,
Am I?
It's interesting.
What if it really happened, right?
We just had a famous athlete
ask a question one second ago.
What if
Tom Brady hit me up and asked me?
Would I be like, "Oh, Tom I wish you're
leg fell off your body."
The answer's no, I'm not that human right.
And the truth is, it's actually
very hard for me to be upset
with an athlete, even
though that's where I get
sports muscles aka you guys know
what beer muscles are right?
Somebody get's drunk and they wanna fight.
I get sports muscles.
I'm at a sporting event, I wanna fight.
But outside of it, especially right now
in non football season,
I feel like I'm almost
becoming a caricature of myself
outside the football environment
of hating the Patriots
and it was really interesting.
I literally thought about that yesterday.
So, being honest with myself,
if he hit me up and asked me a question,
I'd probably give him the best
sound advice that I could.
And I'd try, 'cause
there's still a good part--
as I was just about to say that
(laughs)
there was a part of my...
There's a part of me is
like, "This is the moment
where I can finally put
the nail in the coffin
and sabotage him."
I mean, the truth is he's getting close
to the end of his career.
It's funny,
Kobe, hated him my whole life.
Like just hated him, sorry.
But now I kinda root for him
because he's an underdog.
I love underdogs, right.
And I think Tom is the complete
and utter reverse of that
in our society today and in my division.
So it makes me very easy to dislike him.
Look, he destroyed his phone,
systematically
to conceal the evidence.
Nobody in public domain,
no matter what he does
is going to believe him.
So many people over and
over talk about the fact
that people don't care
that much about the crime,
they care about the coverup.
It's unbelievable what America does
with the coverup versus the actual crime.
Literally probably right up to
where it gets to the ultimate
like a murder, I don't
think we're like, all right.
But underneath that, I mean there's like--
I don't need to say 'em out loud.
There's four to five things
in society that can be done
where the issue is the issue.
But boy, all those
thousands of other things
they're actually things
we're more than willing
to let go away because
we have all have empathy
to know that we're not
perfect and we all have our
skeletons in our closets.
It's when you try to trick us
after we, the collective United States,
the collective world,
have put you on such a pedestal
and you've been rewarded with the riches
that come along with that.
And so I would say to him to have empathy
and to understand why it's happened.
And I would probably tell
him, which ugh it sucks
but this is what I'd tell him.
I'd probably tell him look, the truth is,
the more you fight this, the worst.
The more you approach it with empathy,
it is what it is.
The chips have fallen.
You're probably too
emotional or passionate
to apologize or admit.
I don't think you have to do that.
I think you just have to go neutral
for a long enough period of time
and I don't think anybody
cares 24 months ago--
from now other than passionate Patriot
and anti-Patriot fans that debate this
for the rest of your career.
Out of fondness of debating around sports.
That's probably what I would tell him.
That's it?
- [India] That's it.
- That's it.
All right.
So, with that, I hope everybody
has a tremendous weekend.
I thought that was a really good show.
Clearly 'cause it's the,
I'm gonna need a graphic
here for his Zak.
Because it's the Golden Era.
(laughs)
Dallas, you know what,
you just happen to have
the right spot to do this.
I'm gonna allow you to ask
the question of the day.
- Okay.
- And so, you don't have as
much time as you think, go.
- Right.
My question of the day is this,
What motivates you
to do what you do?
- It's a good one, very solid.
Way to know the audience.
Thanks for being on the show.
- Thank you.
- Thanks for recording the show.
- [Matt] Thank you.
- Thanks for asking questions on the show.
(laughs)
- Thank you.
- You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
- [DRock] That guy
taking over my job.
Not cool.
♫ I'm on top of the ocean
♫ Living like life ain't frozen
♫ Feelin' my feet been chosen
♫ For something other than motion
(hip hop music)
♫ Mama told me I'mma be somebody
♫ I ain't never gone need nobody no no
♫ I ain't never gone need nobody
♫ No cliffhanger
♫ Yes I do banger
♫ I'm the new Mick Jagger
♫ Didn't do it for the girls
♫ Do it for the money
♫ Didn't do it for the fame
♫ Now I do